MAYBE LOOK AT THE SOCIAL MEDIA
ASPECT OF WHAT MIGHT BE GOING
THROUGH THEIR MIND.
TRACE, STAY WITH US.
WE’RE GOING TO GET BACK TO YOU
IN A SECOND.
WE GO BACK TO PARKLAND.
PHIL, I DON’T THINK THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL CAN HEAR ME.
IF SHE COULD GO INTO THE WHOLE
ASPECT OF A SOCIAL MEDIA
IMPRINT, WHAT SOME OF THESE
SHOOTERS ARE SAYING ONLINE.
ARE WE CAPTURING ENOUGH OF THIS?
ARE WE PAYING ENOUGH ATTENTION
TO THAT?
>> ALL RIGHT, SEAN.
THE FIRST THING HE WANTS ME TO
ASK YOU BEFORE WE GET TO WHAT
YOU SAID WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
TODAY IS SOCIAL MEDIA AND WHAT
SOME OF THESE KILLERS AND
ACCUSED KILLERS IN THESE MASS
MURDERS AND SHOOTING SPREES ARE
POSTING OR HINTING AT OR
ALLUDING TO.
WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT THAT FROM A
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WHEN THEY’RE
POSTING IT ON SOCIAL MEDIA, THEY
HAVE FOLLOWERS.
SO KIDS ARE OUT THERE, PARENTS,
YOU’VE GOT TO MONITOR THIS
STUFF.
AND IF YOU SEE IT, TAKE
EVERYTHING SERIOUSLY.
TAKE EVERY THREAT SERIOUSLY AND
REPORT IT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE WOULD RATHER YOU DO THAT THAN
BE WRONG 99% OF THE TIME THAN
HAVE ANYTHING HAPPEN IN THIS
WORLD.
AND THESE TEENS NOW ARE VOCAL ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THEY DON’T JUST POP UP FROM
ANYWHERE.
THERE ARE WARNING SIGNS.
IF YOU SEE WARNING SIGNS WITH
YOUR CHILD, IF YOU KNOW SOME OF
YOUR KIDS’ FRIENDS, YOU NEED TO
REPORT IT.
YOU NEED TO GO TO SCHOOL
COUNSELORS.
YOU NEED TO LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT
SOMETHING ISN’T RIGHT.
>> LAST SUMMER YOU SPENT SO
MUCH TIME IN ORLANDO FOR THE
PULSE NIGHTCLUB SHOOTING.
HOW SICKENED WERE YOU TODAY WHEN
YOU GOT THE CALL?
>> IT WAS HEARTBREAKING.
AND IMMEDIATELY I CAME DOWN
HERE.
BUT ON MY WAY DOWN, I ALSO WENT
TO LAS VEGAS WHEN THEY HAD THE
MASS SHOOTING AT THE CONCERT OUT
THERE.
STILL KEEP IN TOUCH WITH, SHE
HAS A BULLET LODGED IN HER
SPINE.
SHE CONTACTED ME ON MY DOWN AND
SHE’S SO TRAUMATIZED, CRYING,
SAYING SHE’S STILL PRAYING FOR
THE VICTORIES HERE.
WE HAVE PARTNERED WITH THE GREAT
MEN AND WOMEN OF THE FBI WHO ARE
VICTIMS ADVOCATES WITH MINE AND
WE’RE WORKING TO GET THESE
FAMILIES THROUGH THIS, TO GET
THEM THE COUNSELING, THE HELP
THEY NEED, AND TO NOT BE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF DURING THIS
TRAGEDY.
>> ATTORNEY GENERAL BONDI HAS
BEEN KNOWN FOR REALLY TOUGH LAW
AND ORDER ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
IF WE CAN’T MONITOR EVIL THAT’S
IN PEOPLE’S HEARTS, IS IT TIME
-- WHAT ABOUT RETIRED MILITARY,
RETIRED POLICE IN EVERY SCHOOL?
AT LEAST HAVE SOME FRONTLINE OF
DEFENSE TO GIVE SOME CAPACITY TO
STOP CARNAGE WHEN IT STARTS LIKE
THIS.
>> AS AN AGGRESSIVE LAW
ENFORCER AND THE CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN THE STATE
OF FLORIDA, THE FOURTH MOST
POPULOUS STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
>> THIRD.
IS IT FEASIBLE AND PLAUSIBLE,
AND SHOULD WE DO IT, START
HAVING ARMED GUARDS AT EVERY
SCHOOL, IF NOT ARMED GUARDS, DO
YOU HAVE RETIRED MILITARY OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PROVIDE A BEEFIER
SCENARIO IN AND AROUND SCHOOLS
AS A FORM OF DETERRENT?
>> I FIRMLY AGREE WITH THAT.
YES, THAT’S WHY WE HAVE SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS.
DO THEY NEED MORE HELP?
YES.
OF COURSE IF WE HAVE THE FUNDING
FOR IT, I THINK WE DO, I THINK
WE NEED THAT NOW.
THAT’S WHAT WE’RE SEEING AROUND
THIS WORLD.
AND WE HAVE TO PROTECT OUR KIDS
FROM THESE MONSTERS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED ME
TONIGHT AND WE TALKED AT LENGTH.
HE IS HEARTBROKEN AND PRAYING
FOR ALL THESE FAMILIES.
HOW ARE THE FAMILIES?
AND THAT’S WHERE I’M HEADED NOW,
TODAY MY JOB AS ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND WITH MY ADVOCATES, PROVIDE
COUNSELING, FUNERAL EXPENSES AND
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELING FOR ALL
THESE TRAUMATIZED VICTIMS AS
WELL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SCHEDULED
TO BE IN ORLANDO IN LIGHT OF
THIS.
DID HE INDICATE WHETHER HE WOULD
ALSO BE MAKING A VISIT DOWN
HERE?
>> ALL WE TALKED ABOUT, HIS
ONLY CONCERN TONIGHT IS THE
VICTIMS, AS IT SHOULD BE.
ALL HE ASKED ABOUT WERE, "HOW
ARE THE VICTIMS?
HOW ARE THE FAMILIES?"
SHE WAS SO WORD ABOUT -- HE WAS
SO WORRIED ABOUT THE FAMILY AND
THE VICTIMS.
>> AND GRANTED, WE ARE VERY
EARLY INTO THE PROSECUTION OF
THIS CASE.
BUT CLEARLY HE’S 19 YEARS OLD.
HE IS ELIGIBLE FOR THE DEATH
PENALTY, ELIGIBLE FOR FULL
CONVICTIONS ON MURDER, MULTIPLE
COUNTS AND LIFE IN PRISON.
>> WELL, YOU’RE TALKING TO A
CAREER PROSECUTOR WHO HAS
PROSECUTED DEATH PENALTY CASES.
WE DON’T KNOW THE  --
>>AND I CAN’T TALK ABOUT THE
FACTS NOW, BUT GIVEN WHAT I
KNOW, I WOULD FIRMLY BELIEVE IT
WOULD BE A DEATH PENALTY CASE.
>> THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
HERE.
HE SAID, AS A GRANDPARENT, A
PARENT, YOU SEE THIS ON THE NEWS
AND WONDER COULD THIS HAPPEN TO
ME?
YOUR HEART SINKS.